four traits they have to look into
business and then the fifth one is the
most important number one is that you
wanna find a niche that has pain so you
wanna have a problem that you can
actually solve number two is you want
something that's growing because the end
of the day business is hard either way
you might as well go serve a marketplace
that's getting bigger rather than
getting smaller so you want to sell for
e-commerce stuff not for newspapers
number three is you want to make sure
that the people you're trying to sell to
actually have money you could try and
sell to wealthy doctors or you could try
and sell to people who are on
unemployment which one do you think
you'll be able to charge more for the
fourth is that you need to find a way to
target them easily you have two
different ones and one's easier to reach
check that one and then the fifth one
and this is the most important one you
want to pick the person or the niche
that you can provide the most value to
and so this comes from having experience
of some sort or some sort of
relationship to that niche otherwise
you're going in blind and you're going
to be competing against people who
already know a little bit more than you
and so the easiest thing is just do
something that's close to stuff you
already know and then you can grow from